Good morning, John.
This video’s going to be purely instructional
because your YouTube experience could be better
if you knew some YouTube secrets.
For example, I just flashed some text on the
screen, but you couldn’t read it because
it was only there for one frame, but what
are you gonna do?
You gonna go back and then try to pause at
the exact right second?
No! You're not!
Instead, you’re gonna watch this video,
which has 18 tips for how to use YouTube better,
including how to find that text.
First, though, let’s talk about subscriptions.
If you’re logged in to YouTube and you go
to youtube.com, you will find a page of content
that YouTube has decided that you probably
will want to watch.
It will probably keep you on the site.
But it will not be a feed of videos that you
control.
The only way to get to that is to click on
this little weird icon at the top and go to
subscriptions.
Also under that icon is your history, so you
can see videos you recently watched, and your
watch later playlist, which is a wonderful
thing because often you see a video that you
want to watch but you don’t have time to
watch at that exact moment.
Every YouTube video has a little clock.
If you hover over it, you can click that,
it adds to your watch later playlist.
Then you can click on that either on your
desktop or on your phone, whatever you want,
and watch those videos.
The majority of nerdfighters who answered
the nerdfighteria census get their YouTube
videos from the subscriptions feed, and that
is wonderful for us because it’s the only
page on YouTube where you can go and actually
make sure you’re seeing all the content
your favorite creators are making.
But the subscription page, if you got a lot
of subscriptions, like I do, can be a bit
of a fire hose.
It makes it easier to miss content from the
people I never want to miss stuff from, which
is why, for certain channels, I have notifications
turned on.
It’s a little bell thing, you click on it,
and decide how you want to get the notification.
You can also do this from your subscription
manager page.
You can see all the people you’re subscribed
to, maybe take out the ones that you’re
not watching so much anymore.
And for the ones you never want to miss a
video from, you can turn on notifications.
You can also set up notifications on your
phone—the little bell on a channel page.
You can get push notifications every time
a new video gets uploaded, and you can join
that coveted group, the notification squad,
if you’ve ever seen that comment.
Your subscription feed is actually easier
to find on mobile, it’s one of the big buttons
at the top, and now that some YouTubers, including
us, have the ability to post community posts
that aren’t videos but will show up in your
mobile subscription feed, you can decide whether
or not you want to see those community posts.
For now, I’d suggest turning that on, trying
it out, because we’re gonna be messing
around with it some in the coming weeks.
This is all fine and good when you’re on
your phone or on your computer, but what about
if you wanna be on the big screen?
Well, if you have any kind of smart-enabled
television that’s sharing a Wi-Fi connection
with your phone or your computer, a little
icon will show up, and you can click it, and
send your YouTube straight to your TV.
And if you’re on your phone while you’re
watching the video, you can queue up the next
video and the next video and then, it’s
great!
It’s frickin—it works like a dream!
Youtube has its problems; this is not one
of them.
I use it all the time.
Now, finally, back to desktop to talk about
hot keys.
Now, because of a weird confluence of things
that’s not really worth talking about, sometimes
if you press the space bar, it will pause
the video.
Sometimes it will jump down to the comment
box, which will be extremely frustrating,
‘cause then you have to scroll up and then
press pause, and you’re like, why didn’t
the space bar just work?
But if you push the “K” key, it will always
pause the video.
“L” will advance 10 seconds, and “J”
will go back 10 seconds.
These keys being used for this purpose is
actually a holdover from old video editing software,
and a lot of people think that it’s
annoying and weird and like it doesn’t make
any sense that it’s those particular keys,
but I actually kind of love it.
And there are a bunch of other hot keys.
“M” will mute the video, the up and down
arrows will make the volume go up and down,
the left and right arrows will advance and
reverse the video 5 seconds.
The numbers on your keyboard will advance
the video to that point in the video, so if
you like hit “6,” it will go to 60% of
the way through the video.
If you hit “0,” it will go back to the
beginning.
The “greater than” or “less than”
keys will speed up or slow down the video.
And finally, the period and comma will advance
and reverse one frame at a time,
allowing you finally to catch that weird one frame
of text that the creator decided
to put on the screen just to mess with you.
If you’re on your TV or phone, though I
got—I got nothing for you.
You just gotta pause and unpause real quick.
If anybody else has any tips or tricks for
how they use YouTube most efficiently,
I really wanna see those in the comments.
John, I’ll see you on Tuesday.